in the heart of the Gridiron there
exists the Brotherhood of extraordinary
athletes black quarterbacks for every
two steps forward they've encountered
one step back yet their resilience never
folded through the noise
from MVPs to Super Bowls
black quarterbacks have left their mark
on the canvas of football history for
generations and that as a new day does a
record-breaking number of starting black
quarterbacks take the stage greatness
begins and ends with these brothers okay
we're proving that we should have been
playing the whole time we needed some of
the best quarterbacks in the league
you
[Music]
understand hopefully people understand
black quarterbacks The Architects of
change the Guardians of Dreams creators
of Swag and